[Music]
what does it take to become the absolute
best at something is it an unwavering
unquestionable self-belief he needs a
multi-kill first found twist aggressing
they have to double peak he's getting
his shots
is it the countless hours of grueling
practice
maybe it's just a natural god-given
talent as xy has to shine through in a
one-on-two he's got the first he's not
in the second silence of god he is above
anything else this can create or maybe
it has to do with a bit of luck here is
pearson
oh what
what
jack in a box pops up and takes antares
out in the spawn with the flying deagle
now for most players it's probably a
combination of all of these things but
in the case of csgo legend dennis edmond
better known as dennis his specific
talent
remains a bit of a mystery i just
play the game and
i'm good at the pieces i don't know why
and throughout his long career as one of
his game's most feared frugal skull
shatterers
dennis didn't need to explain much
instead he preferred to let his pistol
do the talking dennis is extremely good
on these pistols to start that momentum
off fast play very fast play and there
it is oh my god dennis on cue on point
all three kills again
i'm done don't even buy guns just this
guy could use a usb for the entire game
and i would be convinced
because g2 certainly has to be convinced
it might be
with an absolutely perfect round but
that legendary penchant for punishing
challengers when his teams needed it
most earned dennis a cult-like status
one that saw him get branded by fans as
cs goes
pistol god crosby that
nba
so how is it that dennis was able to
push his contemporaries to raise their
game using counter-strike's thriftiest
arsenal how did a case of bad luck and
unfortunate timing deny him a
much-deserved major and more importantly
with the spry new generation of
highlight machines today
is dennis still cs goes pistol
on highway
[Music]
all right so before we get into the
video it is that time again where i
shamelessly tell you to like the video
subscribe to our channel and please
please please turn on notifications
because rest assured we got some really
cool offbeats coming down the pipeline
now for anyone who is unfamiliar with
the scalp collecting menace that is
dennis
please allow me to enlighten you on the
surface he might look like your standard
tatted up stoic swedish killing machine
but the truth is he can barely contain
himself when it comes to clapping his
opponents
and while dennis specializes in
disrespecting his opposition on the
server he isn't shy of playfully
throwing shade at even his teammates off
of it i just wanted to say that
i'm much better than olaf
of course that boundless confidence
might explain the ridiculous highlights
that dennis has been able to create over
the years even though from time to time
it's also been known to backfire dennis
no way
make it happen
what is going on but out of everything
you need to know about dennis there is
only one thing that really matters
the dude can click heads
like
specifically heads they're probably not
going to win the round anyway and yeah
dennis is even catching frags on the
exit with the usp two kills dropping
coldzera and bolts and all dropped
dennis we know he's the pistol master
but that is a little bit too much so uh
he has managed to escape all the way
back the one time coming in that's the
bomb carry as well perfect flashbang
kishimo stuck in the corner but there
are more team players coming in but
there are more headshots coming in from
dennis
yeah all of my helping and as well
dennis gets to reload in and he gets the
jumping headshot onto kiyoshima and then
the long range finish on reign so ct's
are streaming in tempo gives them a man
advantage jw uh jdm's gonna contribute
as well dennis and flush the remaining
two back someone coming into them it's
all turning around now at least alone
gonna get taken down dennis again
doing monstrous damage for fnatic like
many of his swedish compatriots dennis
got his start in cs 1.6 where he played
alongside a who's who of would-be
counter-strike royalty but it was when
he made the jump to cs go in 2012 that
dennis really started making a name for
himself there's the all from jw and
dennis gets a great double there
amazing from dennis despite the obvious
skill he had for the game the early part
of dennis's cs go career didn't yield
the results and financial stability he
was hoping for and so in 2014 he decided
to walk away from counter-strike in 2014
i took up kejer a year and a half away
from gun strike because like it wasn't
giving me any money pretty much like i
had to get a job when i was working i
didn't
watch that much of count strike i didn't
really care about it that much and then
i spoke to
olaf and he said like yeah like
it's getting better there's good
salaries and like you should come back
and so i did with the promise of a more
stable career dennis returned to cs go
with a roster that would eventually
become g2 esports and despite his
prolonged absence from the scene
it was clear that he had not missed a
step dennis
is off in ct sky
lurking above it's not a good position
though oh he's gonna be
oh
the second one as well dennis is a
machine there's a third player oh oh my
god how on earth did he pull that one
off 11 hp left at the end of that
amazing stuff from dennis but once again
dennis found himself on a team that
struggled to show up at the business end
of bigger tournaments so after g2
finished third fourth at dreamhack open
cluj napoca dennis decided it was time
to offer his services elsewhere but he
wasn't just looking for any roster no
dennis wanted to win titles and in order
to do just that he linked up with the
best team in the world at that time
fnatic who's gonna be able to put a stop
to them because if fnatic make it to the
finals fnatic don't lose finals
with fnatic dennis had finally landed on
a roster that wasn't just insanely
talented but one that had made a habit
of winning on the game's biggest stages
and it was alongside the likes of krimz
jw flusha and olaf that dennis was able
to establish himself as one of cs go's
most exciting fraggers who stays patient
with the awp and fnatic they'll go back
onto the a site they find another kill
it's kjv that goes down they find a vice
what a shot was that from dennis as they
walk around finally dupre gets the
answer but it's still going to be
another bomb plant for fnatic and then a
close game
the more economy you let slip away with
a team like fnatic
the more likely they're going to punish
you for it yet dennis is going to force
the issue this is aggressive playing
this is so aggressive that has gotten
off that's ungodly from dennis it was
with fnatic that dennis finally began
racking up silverware with the team
winning six lanes in a row leading up to
mlg columbus 2016. most important thing
is the major we we really want to win
that one but it was at that major that
the swede's momentum came to a
screeching halt it's jw left it's match
point for australia jw needs to clutch
we've seen it before we need to see it
again he needs to play out of a skin for
his team to survive here but there's too
many angles too many astradas players
zero to two fnatic go astralis move on
fnatic's early exit from columbus kicked
off a string of further disappointing
results but in spite of the team's
overall struggles
one thing people couldn't stop talking
about was dennis's unbelievable skill
with pistols i have some experience
playing dennis on piston rounds in the
past when i was on liquid we played
fanatic on kabul and
we were in like a 3v5 or something and
then dennis kills all five of us
now make no mistake dennis was fully
capable of fragging out with more than
just a budget sidearm but because he was
so much better at using all varieties of
them the community began referring to
him as the pistol god yeah i mean the
other passive aspect of that is they
know there's no one aggressively
there it is nice shot you mentioned it
from dennis he's got two looking for a
third he's gonna find it as well and
flush his chimed in with one more make
it a double for him
that's why matt one of the best pistol
players on the planet that was
absolutely sick
i guess it's just been there this whole
time i haven't practiced it any more
than other guns and like a pissed round
is super important so and it's the most
fun round in the game in my opinion so i
guess that's why why i'm good with
pistols gonna be a happy setup here
dennis is gonna do the best that he can
and this man with a pistol is absolutely
insane three head shots and this is not
going according to plan for vp finally
pasha will find him
but the damage is done and dennis is
insane on v site with the pistol count
on him now this might seem like a minor
thing to get excited about but the truth
is having a reliable pistol wielder on
your roster can make a world of
difference in close matches you see
pistol rounds are important for a
variety of reasons they happen twice a
map set the pace for the first few
rounds of a half which in turn affect
the course of a game and they're fully
capable of making or breaking tight
matchups and while winning pistol
doesn't necessarily guarantee any
specific outcome
knowing that you hold an advantage over
your opponents when the time comes to
frantically tap heads and mumble a
prayer to r jesus can be a game changer
there are still four liquid players
towards me now they know but it's too
late dennis with the fast frag on the
simple sure he could get to return but
the bomb will be planted dennis posting
a defense by the apc now as that bomb
takes away three versus three as dennis
pops more heads is this guy done just
yet i don't even know he's got all of my
stuff for support as well this is a very
tough free entry for liquid once dennis
is getting in there again and there
might be one more of course dennis with
the ace to kick off the second half
fnatic needed that and dennis delivered
but unfortunately for dennis despite
having a standout year that saw him
being named one of hltv's top 20 players
in the world fnatic's struggles
continued and even though dennis was
still producing his moments of magic
does land flashbangs in what the hell is
going on
yes what are you doing another headshot
taking down flamie is he an actual robot
now guardian and simple and left night
there's no recovery from this things
just weren't improving so when fnatic
fell short of yet another major in
krakov in the summer of 2017
dennis decided that it was time for a
change it's annoying in a way because
when when i played with fnatic i thought
we were going to win it and we were
super confident we had a good feeling
we're going to win it because we had a
good bracket
and then we lost i think that was my
best chance at winning the major
that kind of sucks but
it's never too late
keen to play on a swedish stack dennis
joined up with godsend but as much as he
tried that lineup never really lived up
to its namesake there's always something
that you could say was missing whether
it was firepower
whether it was in-game leadership
whether it was team atmosphere that you
could see wasn't really you know on
point there was always something wrong
with that team having already played for
two of sweden's biggest cs orgs dennis
reunited with forest and get right on
nip in the hope that their wealth of
experience could finally secure him his
elusive major trophy but once again it
just wasn't meant to be after a roller
coaster year and a half that saw them
crash out of both the face at london
major and iem katowice 2019 dennis and
nip parted ways in the span of just a
few years dennis had gone from being one
of the best cs go players in the world
to a gun for hire a grizzled mercenary
unable to find a spot on a tier one
roster that could help him reach the top
of the game although not for a lack of
trying
dennis has moved forward dennis has got
a beautiful entry looking for more and
he's so crisp right now does not want to
let his team down
and it's a 3v1 as dennis is making it
all happen all on his lungs from the
veteran spirit
is finally ignited and while he
certainly experienced his fair share of
heartbreak and disappointment over the
course of his career dennis is far from
a tragic figure he has played alongside
some of the greatest players that
counter strike has ever seen he's won
his fair share of trophies and even at
30 years of age he is still as dedicated
as ever to the game that dared him to
dream hopefully i can get to play like
top count strike again that's my my main
goal and i miss it i just want to keep
playing face better teams and just prove
people that i'm still good like i would
still like to achieve more i'm not
satisfied i'm feeling good and i'm i'm
informed i'm in good form right now so
hopefully i can get to play major again
and uh and take one home whether it's a
product of bad luck or poor timing
dennis was just never able to hit the
insane heights that his crazy skill
ceiling all but assured
but the truth is
he's no worse off for it he has built a
legacy that hasn't just cemented his
place in cs go's rich and storied
history but a reputation that follows
him no matter what game he's playing
[Music]
and even if dennis never gets the chance
to claim the major that's missing from
his trophy cabinet there is no question
that he has left his mark on cs go not
only did he elevate the art of pistol
play but he impacted an entire
generation of players who saw his magic
and sought to recreate it themselves
good shooting oh harry please lame
because at the end of the day when you
hang up your mouse for good and call it
a career it isn't the titles you want
that fans are going to look back at and
remember fondly
it's the plays the moments you got them
out of their seats and dared them to
question everything that they thought
was possible on the server and for
dennis it is that catalog of
mind-blowing highlights that will
forever immortalize him as cs goes one
true pistol god we're just picking him
up is the world's best pistol player
not more fitting than he does that in
the second half unbelievable scenes
five kills just a clean ace why not
that's so sick let's go
dennis there's like this myth
see this these cs players have this idea
that the usp is like better than the
glock
absurd ridiculous it's better in one
circumstance like it's better at long
range with with insane first shot
accuracy but in like 80 percent of other
circumstances the glock is the superior
weapon